cette semaine aussi 17 un certain nombre
de films vacances obligent détente
oblige plutôt des comédies dont le
dernier enfin le premier véritable avant
première véritable réalisation de gilles
lellouche pardon le grand bain film très
attendu que je n'ai pas encore vu dont
je peux pas vous en parler mais le film
est très très attendu voilà il est
accompagné du film de michel blanc voyez
comme on danse de star is born de
bradley cooper qui marche très très bien
à la deux pour les jeunes et pour les
plus petits vous pourrez voir y étiez
compagnie chair de poule 2 le très beau
film de michel ocelot d'il y à paris et
pour les ados plutôt la prophétie de
l'horloge voilà pour le programme de
6,17 cette semaine vacances de la
toussaint oblige
[Musique]